♪ I WAN ITEM NA WIN -- I WANNA
WIN.
WILL: WELCOME BACK TO "FOX &
friends", WELCOME BACK TO
TAMPA, FLORIDA, ’EM HOME OF
SUPER BOWL LV.
WE’VE BEEN TALKING TO YOU ALL
WEEKEND ABOUT THE STATE OF
FLORIDA.
THE STATE OF BEING OPEN, THE
STATE OF FREEDOM AND
EXPERIENCING IT HERE DOWN IN THE
SUNSHINE STATE.
THE MAN RESPONSIBLE FOR THAT IS
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTIS, IN
LARGE PART KEEPING THIS STATE
OPENED, AND I’M PLEASED TO BE
JOINED BY THE GOVERNOR HIMSELF.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU.
>> WELCOME TO TAMPA BAY AND TO
THE GREAT STATE OF FLORIDA.
WILL: WHEN HE SAYS HE’S A BUCS
FAN, YOU GREW UP THAT WAY?
>> YEAH.
WHEN THEY HAD THE ORANGE
UNIFORMS, WHEN THEY WERE KIND OF
THE JOKE OF THE NFL, THE
VISITING TEAM WOULD USUALLY HAVE
MORE FANS THAN WE WOULD HAVE, SO
I WAS A SUPPORTER.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE WERE ABLE TO
WIN A SUPER BOWL IN 2003, WHICH
WAS GREAT, BUT WE’VE HAD SOME
LEAN YEARS.
SO TO BE ABLE TO BE HERE AND
HOSTING THE SUPER BOWL WITH THE
BUCS IN IT, WITH TOM BRADY AT
THE HELM, THERE’S A LOT OF
EXCITEMENT HERE IN THE TAMPA PA
BAY AREA.
WILL: ABSOLUTELY.
I’VE MADE THE CASE TO BRING BACK
THOSE CREAM SICKLE UNIFORMS.
I THINK THEY’RE BEAUTIFUL.
[LAUGHTER]
LET’S TALK ABOUT BEING OPEN.
I’VE EXPERIENCED IT, I’VE WITHIN
OUT AND ABOUT IN TAMPA THIS
ENTIRE WEEKEND.
THIS ISN’T THE FIRST
CHAMPIONSHIP YOU’VE HOSTEDDED,
NOT THE FIRST BIG EVENT YOU’VE
HOSTED.
TALK ABOUT YOU OPENING THIS
STATE UP AND WHETHER OR NOT IT’S
BEEN A SUCCESS.
>> WELL, YOU LOOK AROUND THE
COUNTRY, AND THEY STILL ARE
DEBATING WHETHER SCHOOLS SHOULD
BE OPEN.
WE’VE HAD SCHOOLS OPEN THE WHOLE
YEAR.
THEY TALK ABOUT WHETHER
BUSINESSES SHOULD BE OPEN.
EVERY BUSINESS IN THE FLORIDA
HAS A RIGHT TO OPERATE.
THEY TALK ABOUT ALL THESE PEOPLE
UNEMPLOYEDED.
IN FLORIDA EVERY SINGLE PERSON
HAS A RIGHT TO EARN A LIVING,
AND OUR UNEMPLOYMENT RATE IS
LOWER THAN THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
OUR TOURISM MARKET HASN’T
RECOVERED.
OUR COVID THOUGH, WE HAVE LESS
COVID MORTALITY PER CAPITA THAN
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE.
25 STATES OR HIGHER, SO THE
LOCKDOWNS DON’T WORK ON THEIR
OWN, BUT THEY CAUSE CATASTROPHIC
DAMAGE TO SOCIETY.
SO WHAT WE’VE BEEN ABLE TO DO AS
OTHER STATES HAVE TRIED TO LOCK
PEOPLE DOWN, WE’VE TRIED TO LIFT
PEOPLE UP.
AND I TELL YA, EVERY TIME I GO
OUT SOMEONE WILL COME UP TO ME
AND SAY MY KID WASN’T DOING
WELL, THANK YOU FOR GETTING HIM
BACK IN SCHOOL.
OR HI IF BUSINESS WOULD HAVE
FAILED, THANK YOU FOR SAVING IT.
OR I WOULD HAVE LOST MY JOB.
THOSE EFFECTS ARE GOING TO MAKE
THIS STATE SO STRONG GOING
GUARD, AND I THINK HAD WE TRIED
A DIFFERENT COURT THAT HAD NOT
WORKED IN OTHER PLACES, I THINK
IT TAKES YEARS AND YEARS TO
RECOVER FROM THE DAMAGE.
MAYBE DECADES, IN FACT.
WILL: THE DATA’S CLEAR, YOU
KNOW, IT’S COME IN,
HOSPITALIZATIONS, TRANSMISSIONS,
MORTALITY COMBINED WITH THE
ECONOMICS OF BEING OPEN, BUT TEN
THAT LEADS ME TO THIS, AND I
DON’T KNOW IF THERE’S AN EASY
ANSWER TO THIS QUESTION, BUT
OUTSIDE OF A FEW PLACES, THE
NATIONAL MEDIA’S LARGELY USED
YOU AS A POINT OF CRITICISM
WHILE CELEBRATING GOVERNORS LIKE
ANDREW CUOMO.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT IS IN THE
FACE OF ALL THAT EVIDENCE?
>> WELL, LOOK, THEY HAVE A
PARTISAN AGENDA.
IT WAS AN ELECTION YEAR, THEY
DID NOT WANT THE PRESIDENT TO
CARRY FLORIDA.
I THINK THE FACT THAT THE
PRESIDENT ENDORSED ME WHEN I RAN
FOR GOVERNOR, SO THEY HAD A
NARRATIVE.
AND THEIR NARRATIVE IS WHATEVER
HELPS THEM ADVANCE THEIR
POLITICAL -- IT DOESN’T MATTER
ABOUT THE FACTS, THEY WILL
IGNORE FACTS THAT ARE
INCONVENIENT FOR THEIR NARRATIVE
AND EVEN CONCOCT CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AS TO WHY THE FACTS
AREN’T -- SO I THINK THEY’VE
DONE A HORRIBLE JOB WITH WHAT
THEY’VE DONE.
BUT HERE’S THE THING, PEOPLE
AREN’T BUYING IT BECAUSE PEOPLE
VOTE WITH THEIR FEET, AND THEY
ARE FLOODING INTO THIS STATE.
WE HAVE INVESTMENT COMING IN, WE
HAVE PEOPLE BUYING HOME LIKE
NEVER BEFORE, WE HAVE -- JUST
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE SCHOOLS
OPEN, PEOPLE ARE LEAVING IN
EVERY CORNER OF THE STATE JUST
BECAUSE WE HAVE SCHOOLS.
WE’VE HAD SPORTS GOING ON THE
WHOLE TIME.
I HAVE PARENTS WHO HAVE MOVED
THEIR KIDS TO FLORIDA BECAUSE
THEY DIDN’T WANT TO MISS
FOOTBALL SEASON WHICH THEY WOULD
HAVE IN SOME OF THESE LOCKED
DOWN STATES.
SO I THINK THE NARRATIVES THAT
SOME OF THE CORPORATE ELITE
MEDIA TRY TO SELL, PEOPLE DON’T
BUY IT, AND THIS IS A PERFECT
EXAMPLE BECAUSE IF PEOPLE BOUGHT
THEIR NARRATIVE THE, YOU’D HAVE
PEOPLE LEAVING HERE TO GO TO
THESE STATEMENTS THAT ARE
SUPPOSEDLY DOING SO WELL.
WILL: YOU TALKED ABOUT VOTING
WITH THEIR FEET.
BY THE WAY, ARE YOU GOING TO TRY
TO TRANSLATE THOSE INTO VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE’VE GOT A GREAT GOVERNOR’S
ELECTION IN 2022 WHICH WILL BE
VERY IMPORTANT FOR OUR STATE AND
QUITE FRANKLY, I THINK, YOU
KNOW, GIVES US THE ABILITY TO
KEEP THE MOMENTUM GOING.
IS SO THAT’S WHAT WE’RE FOCUSED
ON.
WILL: IS THAT A NO TO RUNNING
FOR PRESIDENT?
>> THAT’S 2022 WE HAVE TO OR
WITH I -- WORRY ABOUT.
WILL I DON’T KNOW IF THIS IS
LIMITED TO CONSERVATIVES, FREE
SPEECH LOVING INDIVIDUALS OUT
THERE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT NOT
NECESSARILY THE GOVERNMENT THIS
TIME, BUT BIG TECH COMPANIES
SUPPRESSING SPEECH.
SEEMINGLY ON ONE SIDE OF THE
AISLE.
YOU HAVE A BILL YOU’RE PUTTING
FORWARD TO TRY TO REIN THAT BACK
IN.
TELL ME ABOUT THAT.
>> SURE.
WELL, ONE, WE WANT TO PROTECT
PEOPLE’S DATA PRIVACY WHICH
THESE BIG COMPANIES REALLY
MANIPULATE AND PROFIT OFF OF.
TWO, WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY’RE NOT INTERFERING IN OUR
ELECTIONS BY DEPLATFORMING
CANDIDATES AND SILENCING PEOPLE
THEY DISAGREE WITH.
BUT THEN ALSO THE BROADER
CENSORSHIP OF SOCIETY.
I MEAN, THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO
WIPE YOU OFF THE MAP ONLINE.
AND IT’S NOT JUST SOMEONE WHO
MAY BE MAKING COMMENTS.
PEOPLE’S BUSINESSES ARE ABLE TO
REACH PEOPLE THROUGH THESE
PLATFORM, PAYMENT PROCESS,
E-MAILS.
THEY’VE WIPED THAT OUT FOR
PEOPLE THEY HAVEN’T LIKED.
THEY’RE ACTING AS MONOPOLIES
THAT ARE EXERTING MORE POWER
THAN THE MONOPOLIES AT THE TURN
OF THE 20TH CENTURY LIKE
STANDARD OIL.
AND SO THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE THIS
MUCH AUTHORITY OVER AMERICAN
LIFE, AND I THINK OUR BILL
REALLY EMPOWERS INDIVIDUALS IF
THEY’RE NOT FOLLOWING THEIR OWN
TERMS OF SERVICE, IF THEY’RE
TARGETING YOU BECAUSE OF YOUR
VIEWPOINT, THAT’SFECTIVELY A
CONSUMER FRAUD.
SO WE’RE ALLOWING THE ABILITY
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO
SUE AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO
BE ABLE TO --
WILL: IF YOU’RE DEPLATFORMED
DURING AN ELECTION CYCLE AND
RUNNING FOR OFFICE?
>> ANYBODY.
ANYBODY.
I MEAN, BECAUSE WHAT THEY TO IS
THEY PLAY GAMES WITH THESE TERMS
OF SERVICE.
THEY DON’T, THEY DON’T IMPLEMENT
IT FAIRLY BECAUSE, JUST THINK
ABOUT IT, THEY WILL DEPLATFORM A
CONSERVATIVE, BUT THEN THE
THEY’LL LET THE AYATOLLAH
KHAMENEI SPOUT ALL THIS ACT
ISRAEL AND JEWS.
SO THAT TYPE OF INCONSISTENCY, I
THINK, GIVES RISE TO A POTENTIAL
CAUSE OF ACTION TO PROTECT
INDIVIDUAL FLORIDIANS’ RIGHTS.
WILL: NO DOUBT.
AND I THINK ALMOST ANY
CONSERVATIVE OUT THERE WOULD
SHARE YOUR CONCERN CULTURALLY,
YOUR CONCERN CAN OVER FREE
SPEECH.
YOU A REPUBLICAN, YOU HAVE --
YOU’RE A REPUBLICAN, IT’S
TRADITIONALLY BEEN A CONCERN
THAT THE GOVERNMENT STEP IN IN
THE WAY OF A PRIVATE INDUSTRY.
I HEARD YOUR REFERENCE STANDARD
OIL.
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT
POTENTIALLY BREAKING UP THE BIG
TECH COMPANIES?
HOW DO WE BALANCE THIS
GOVERNMENT AND FREE PEACH
AGAINST A PRIVATE COMPANY?
>> SO HERE’S THE THING, WE’VE
PAWKED ABOUT LOCKDOWNS AND
FLORIDA’S SUCCESS BEING OPEN.
BIG TECH CENSORED CRITICISMS OF
LOCKDOWNS EARLY IN THE PANDEMIC.
JUST IMAGINE IF WE’D THAT A
ROBUST DEBATE ON THAT.
SOME OF THOSE STATES, MAYBE THEY
WOULD HAVE CHOSE DIFFERENTLY.
BUT IF YOU PUT AN ARTICLE
CRITICIZING -- THEY WOULD TAKE
IT DOWN.
IT WAS BLATANT CENSORSHIP.
AND I THINK IT’S CONTRIBUTED TO
A LOT OF LIVES BEING LOST.
AND SO THIS IS A FUNDAMENTAL
THING.
SO IF BEING ABLE TO STRUCTURE
THE PUBLIC SQUARE AND WHAT WE’RE
DOING IS WE’RE NOT INTERVENING
GOVERNMENT OF TO HAVE LESS
SPEECH, WE’RE TRYING TO
STRUCTURE IT TO HAVE MORE
SPEECH, AND I THINK THAT’S A
FUNDAMENTAL DIFFERENCE TO HOW
OTHER PEOPLE HAVE WANTED TO USE
THE GOVERNMENT IN THE PAST.
IN TERMS OF BREAKING THEM UP,
OBVIOUSLY, THE STATE OF FLORIDA
CAN’T DO THAT, BUT THEY ARE
EXERTING MORE POWER, JUST A
HANDFUL OF COMPANIES, THAN OTHER
INDUSTRIES THAT HAVE BEEN BROKEN
UP IN THE PAST.
I THINK AN ANTITRUST I
PERSPECTIVE NEEDS TO BE PART OF
THIS CONVERSATION.
WILL: WE KNOW THE COST, IT’S
COME IN THE TOLL OF HUMAN LIVES
WHEN YOU’RE SUPPRESSING THE
TRUTH.
WE KNOW THAT WHEN IT COMES TO
COVID.
WE’VE TALKED ABOUT THE ECONOMY,
NOW LET’S BRING THIS HOME.
DO YOU WANT TO ENDORSE THE CREAM
SICKLE UNIFORMS?
[LAUGHTER]
GIVE ME YOUR SUPER BOWL
PREDICTION.
ARE YOU GOING TO SURPRISE ME AND
PICK THE CHIEFS?
>> I PICKED THE CHIEFS PUBLICLY
LAST YEAR, I SAID MAHOMES IS THE
BEST PLAYER IN THE LEAGUE,
THEY’RE GOING TO WIN, AND I
THINK THE POINT SPREAD I GOT WAS
PRETTY CLOSE.
AND I TOLD GOVERNOR PARSONS FROM
MISSOURI WE WELCOME THE CHIEFS
AGAIN, BUT WE WELCOME THEM WITH
MORE HESITANCY AND, QUITE
FRANKLY, WE ARE ROOTING FOR THE
BUCS.
I THINK THAT THEY’RE GOING TO
WIN.
I REMEMBER THE GAME IN WEEK 12,
KANSAS CITY OUTPLAYED US, THAT’S
FINE.
BUT THEY’RE CLICKING NOW.
THE DEFENSE IS PLAYING A LOT
BETTER, TOM BRADY’S REALLY TAKEN
THE REINS IN TERMS OF STRATEGY.
SO I THINK THEY’RE GOING TO DO
IT.
I THINK IT’LL BE TOM BRADY’S
SEVEN SUPER BOWL AND ONE OF THE
GREAT ACHIEVEMENTS IN NFL
HISTORY, IF HE CAN GET THAT
DONE.
WILL: CAN’T WAIT TO SEE IF YOUR
PROGNOSTICATION SKILLS ARE ON
POINT.
NEWS AND SPORTS PUT TOGETHER, I
WANT TO BRING THAT CONVERSATION
YOU AND I WERE HAVING JUST OVER
THERE, WE’VE TALKED ABOUT STATES
BEING SHUT DOWN, PLACES LIKE
CALIFORNIA.
LOOK, HIGH SCHOOL KIDS IN
CALIFORNIA, THEY HAVEN’T HAD A
FOOTBALL SEASON.
SOME OF THESE KIDS TRYING TO
SIGN WITH COLLEGES LAST WEEK,
THEY COULDN’T BECAUSE THEY DID
NOT HAVE A SENIOR SEASON TO
SHOWCASE ANY OF THEIR TALENT.
YOU WERE TELLING ME AND, IN
FACT, THAT HAS BEEN ANOTHER DRAW
TO THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
>> YEAH.
SO, IN FACT, THE GUY THAT WON
MR. FOOTBALL IN FLORIDA, THE
QUARTERBACK UP IN NORTHWEST
FLORIDA, HE HAD BEEN MORE OF A
BASEBALL PLAYER.
HE PLAYED FOOTBALL, BUT HE
REALLY HAD A TREMENDOUS YEAR AND
NOW IS ABLE TO GET SCHOLARSHIP
OFFERS.
AND WE HAD SUPPORT SHUT DOWN,
THAT WOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED.
THAT’S JUST ONE EXAMPLE, BUT YOU
MULTIPLY THAT ACROSS THIS
COUNTRY, THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF KIDS WHOSE
DREAMS WERE SIMPLY CUT SHORT.
IN FLORIDA WE SAID WE’RE
STANDING BY YOUR DREAMS, WE’RE
GOING TO BE THERE FOR YOU.
YOU HAVE EVERY RIGHT TO PLAY.
IF YOU DON’T WANT TO, DON’T DO
IT, BUT WE’RE NOT GOING TO TAKE
THAT AWAY.
WE HAD SUCCESSFUL YOUTH SPORTS
SEASONS SO FAR, WE’RE GOING TO
KEEP IT GOING.
WILL: MENTAL HEALTH, FUTURE
PROSPECTS, BUSINESS AND THE
ECONOMY, IT IS GREAT TO SEE
PEOPLE LIVING AS NORMAL A LIFE
AS THEY CAN.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS